[Music]
all right
well some women have come out to say
that
they they're actually really glad that
the quarantine has happened because it
has helped them a lot in their own
workspace for example the fact that they
have gotten pregnant
and they didn't announce it to any other
colleagues until like right before their
their pregnancy or the maternity leave
and it just seems to
to be a really interesting time because
now like a lot of people are working
from home
so they are able to conceal an entire
pregnancy and not even tell anyone but
and that's a good thing compared to
before yeah because before
a student excuse me as soon as people
find out that you're pregnant all of a
sudden they think that you lost a [ __ ]
ton of brain cells and they don't
respect you anymore and in the workplace
they treat you differently i thought it
would be like everyone caters to you now
and gives you really good treatment no
well you would think it's yeah it's very
misogynistic in the workplace still for
women unfortunately especially has she
lost some brain cells
you know she she's had the occasional
brain fart and
i'm quick to be like prego brain do you
remember the actual like uh
point of conception no because we had
like a [ __ ] marathon for like a week
so i don't know what actual day but it
wasn't quarantined right
yes yes yes it's all part of the plan is
the baby gonna
be named quarantina uh yes uh
i don't hate it i really don't hate it
that's funny uh but
that's interesting i mean to be honest i
have that same thought i'm single right
now so
i'm kind of pissed that i'm single
because this would have been the perfect
time to like have that baby that i don't
have time to have
not gonna lie it's pretty like it's like
perfect yeah because like
you're there for the whole process yeah
otherwise i would have maybe been like
traveling or shooting
or maybe we're doing some foods or doing
college shows like this
i have a reason to just be home you know
what i'm saying and probably
like the next and you have a clear
schedule to be home too yeah
yeah it really is a blessing in disguise
i i wish i i wish i was pregnant
that's what i'm saying i wish i was
pregnant so sliding sherry's being i
definitely
want to have kids for sure without a
doubt and my mom like
asks me every [ __ ] week if i'm going
to freeze my eggs like
she's like reminding me to freeze my
eggs um so
for 50
do you think you'll go through with that
i i think i should because i'm 30 which
isn't like
so so oh but you know hey she's
[ __ ] young okay yeah that's what he
said that's literally what i just said
no but truly though i mean i'm 31 in
november yeah i'm 31 in a a
month so take talk you know wait when's
your birthday
november 10th oh [ __ ]
you all wanted to have a moment like
imagine
what's yours the 29th oh nice so you're
sagittarius
okay it's fine it's fine we'll work
through the differences
um well you're not a sag no i'm a
scorpio
a little scorpio scarfies
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i'm also 39. i mean well
no one was asking that
nine years wait well first of all what
is your [ __ ]
secret [ __ ] you look so good he's not
he's not three he's not wait 22.
okay what the [ __ ] is the secret what's
the truth here we're all 17
okay just let's keep that rumor going um
but i definitely uh think why not just
uh freeze the eggs because you know you
don't
use it half the time how do you freeze
the eggs so you just you
you it's ice trays they jam
you go somewhere with really cold
weather they put the bottom half of
their body in a freezer
for like an hour and then reach up there
and pull it up
you get someone to smoke like a menthol
jewel and you
blow it into your vagina it freezes up
pluck it out
no so they they hang in on the christmas
tree oh god
oh [ __ ] only bring it out during winter
that's it we're gonna go we gotta go
uh so they surgically like extract eggs
extract like with a needle um and some
people only have a
certain amount you know like so some
people grab 16 some people grab like
four
you know so you need to check on the
status of your eggs i heard that before
you even do the procedure you have to do
like
months of injections and it takes an
insane toll on your body and it's like
not months i think i have friends who've
done it i think maybe a week maybe a
couple of weeks or something
of injections uh it's like 10 to 14 days
of injections like maybe twice a day or
something
i don't know i'm literally making this
up dr fauci
take this food three times a day yeah so
um the process is like insanely
much more complicated complicated than
just jerking in
right and sperm donating which is back
to the misogynistic
world um and and the inequality just to
get really deep right now
oh just like conversation uh but yeah
i'm thinking about doing it you want
should we get should we go should we get
a little bogo deal
let's do it oh groupon two for one
groupon
living social something delivery freeze
like let's say uh you weren't like
you'd be down to just have a baby
um let's say you get like would you like
a sperm donor or what would you do yeah
because there's a lot of guys that will
probably just hook you up
right that's why i'm here that's what
i'm here
actually auditioning all of you well the
only option is joe to be honest with you
i apologize
that's what my baby's gonna come out
looking like no i can give you sperm you
we don't have to
have sex you would be down with that
maybe cheese [ __ ] loves me and i love
chia we couldn't
work this out um if you don't wanna have
a short baby
i'm pretty sure too so it's going to be
like a little baby
little baby no
okay everyone focus um no i i
first of all i'm bisexual just for
everyone curious because i would
either have a guy well here's the thing
the egg freezing is like the
the insurance the last resort the you
know backup security right
so basically let's say i don't want to
have a family until i'm like 37
i mean i'm sorry that's not even old
like let's say 45. oh my god i'm just
making up
45. let's say my body has like timed out
and then that's when i
want to have a baby with my husband or
my wife
or my non-binary lover um
and let's see we have the sperm he's
good so then we would just get my egg
and they would inject his sperm and my
egg
in my body and i would still have oh
wait or would i have to use a surrogate
at that point i'm not sure
yeah oh well it depends on my body still
doing it on the health of your uterus
yeah it's all it's all about your little
uterus there i guess we'll be in touch
i'll keep you posted yeah
i'll keep you posted but yeah our
friends just went through ivf and
finally
got a successful yeah no it's a
beautiful process
it's honestly such a beautiful thing
multiple miscarriages it was really
tough
yeah yeah yeah but their journey was
crazy
it's it's just it's not that easy to
have a baby you know
and it's just like when it finally
happens
it's a blessing i creampied a lot and i
thought i was gonna [ __ ] be a dad but
it didn't happen
it's hard when you want it and then it's
easy when you don't watch no
what the [ __ ] well it was hard when i
didn't want it too
it's like going viral like we said you
can't you can't plan it
i know because there's only like a 48
hour window that you can actually get
pregnant
the whole month there's only 48 hours
yeah it's so weird
we shouldn't tell the kids that though
yeah
wrap your sperm is way more potent than
mine that's why
yeah i don't know i feel like the young
pungent i don't even this is not even
backed by science at all it's
just my feeling but i'm like does do do
women younger women
ovulate more often when they're younger
because there's like way more
probability of you getting pregnant i
think so
right because the egg is more fresh
is that ours is it isn't it like a
monthly thing you
oh ovulate you mean more like you more
than once a month
i don't know because i was on this one
birth control pill that
it gave me my period twice a month and
i'm like oh doesn't mean that i'm
ovulating oh no i don't know well that's
why they say the best time to have sex
is literally when you're on your period
because there's like zero chance of
well not zero but it's just less
but it's not depends on how hard you
come
right how far you shoot yeah how
explosive the jizz is
right right right after your period
because that means that the egg already
left
oh good to know it's so weird because
when we when me and cheer were trying
and she broke it down
don't wait a week longer though because
then that's when you're ovulating right
because she was so
like methodical with the [ __ ] right
broke it down took her temperature
all that and it's like really when you
break it down
you guys are really only fertile for
like two days
there's like a really small window you
know what i'm saying so it's like
sperm live for up to like five days so
then that's why they tell you to have
sex for a whole week before you ovulate
you're like stocked up on the cub yeah
and then yeah they're just waiting
they're in there like come on man
where's this [ __ ] egg bro
i'm just waiting just swimming around
i'm first [ __ ] i only got five
days
come on [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they're saying like the x chromosome
sperms they swim
slower which are like the girl ones they
swim slower and but they live
longer but they live longer [ __ ] and
then
the boy ones the y ones they swim faster
but they die faster
dudes be dying faster yeah that's true
in life right i know
it sounds like even human nature right
because you all be stressing us out
man like crazy that's the tactic we're
trying to get rid of all of you
every time my dad is like super annoyed
with my mom or they've been like arguing
he's always like
she has a plan she's trying to get rid
of me
that's awesome they're so cute
is everyone here the only child i i know
you are the only child
pretty much i guess my brother's 12
years older oh
yeah i'm the only child
uh my answer is weird okay fine oh wait
i'm sorry i technically my answer is
weird too i do have two half sisters
oh so you have one whole system that's
[ __ ] up right
that's it
[Laughter]
quick but we haven't taken the
fraternity test but you know um
but but yeah i always uh when i do have
kids i definitely want like at least
three
like i want three three i want like two
boys
boomer babies i'm trying to you know
what i mean be i'm trying to have my own
little
willow and jaden i want more kids too
but i need more moms to help them
no i need to move to utah i need more
moms to help you
i need to be mormon yeah just have a lot
of wives
never say never you could definitely not
say you gotta start freezing these
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying
right exactly otherwise joe when you and
i are both 50
yeah we kill each other all right oh
[ __ ] i'll hook you up
not even have a baby damn you know what
i always like wanted as a younger
person is like i wanted to in my head i
was like it'd be sweet to have a baby
with a girl of every different
nationality so i could see
how i would look as all these different
nations
i call that genghis kum yeah like like a
king's mindset
a little sampler plan a little flight if
you will
but i even knew that like depending on
who it is within that ethnicity would
come out different too yeah because
are they hot right i mean only the
hottest for the king
[Laughter]
and also it's like the probability of
like the dna and whatever whatever like
what if one of them isn't hot then you
almost want to do another one with that
same person just think it's the second
one
you gotta do a re-do sometimes that have
all the hot babies you have siblings and
then like there's like one hot one and
it was like what happened to the other
ones
right it's like danny devito and arnold
schwarzenegger one just took all the
all the good jeans that happens oh man
i don't know what the article is about
[Music]